well the U.S says military trainers from
Iran are in Crimea helping Russian
troops use iranian-made drones to in
attacks on Ukraine Washington believes
Iranian drones hit the capital cave and
energy facilities across the country
Iran has not reacted to the latest U.S
accusations but denies the drones are
Iranian made
we can confirm that Russian military
personnel based in Crimea have been
piloted piloting excuse me Iranian uavs
and using them to conduct kinetic
strikes across Ukraine including
and Strikes against Kiev in in recent
dates we assess that Iranian Personnel
Iranian military personnel were on the
ground in Crimea and assisted Russia in
these operations Russia has received
dozens of these uavs so far and will
likely continue to receive additional
shipments uh in the future
well we'll speak to Muhammad Val in
Moscow in a moment but first let's go to
Muhammad Jam Jun in cave and Muhammad uh
what's the reaction been there when it
comes to any Iranian involvement with
these drones
well Tom there was a statement that was
issued earlier today by the general
staff of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
that statement read in part that the
Russian Federation is transporting
Iranian instructors to prepare and train
drone operators to utilize the Shaheed
136 and the arashtrons those are the
drones that are known more commonly
these days as Kamikaze drones here in
Ukraine against Ukrainian forces
um it's interesting that this statement
did not go into detail as far as where
this is happening because there have
been reports over the course of the past
week in Ukrainian media Outlets
which have stated that there are
according to their sources Iranian
instructors Personnel in Crimea and that
they are helping to train Uh Russian
forces to utilize those Kamikaze drones
against Ukrainian targets throughout
this country this is all coming at a
time when the Ukrainian officials at all
levels of government have been uh have
been echoing the fact they are very
concerned uh about all this and they
have been accusing very publicly Iran of
equipping Russian Fighters with these
Kamikaze drones of course we should
mention that Iran has repeatedly denied
that they are helping Russia in their
efforts in Ukraine or that they are
delivering these drones to the Russian
forces we have also heard in the past
few days from the Ukrainian foreign
minister he said that he was submitting
a proposal to Ukrainian president
velodimir zielinski to formally cut
diplomatic ties with Iran on that as a
result of these accusations from
Ukrainian officials that the Iranians
have been delivering these Kamikaze
drones to uh to the Russian Federation
and I should mention that there have
been numerous drone strikes over the
course of the past week in many parts of
this country drone strikes that have
been targeting critical infrastructure
especially power plants and that's one
of the reasons people are so concerned
right now because at a time when
temperatures are dropping precipitously
and winter is fast approaching people
are really worried that they are going
to be without power in fact the
government has said repeatedly over the
course of the past few days that people
should prepare themselves for perhaps
rolling power outages and they are
desperately asking people to try as best
they can to conserve on the consumption
of energy all being said though Tom once
again the Iranians have repeatedly
denied that they are supplying the
Russians with any of these drones that
are being utilized to attack facilities
across Ukraine Tom thanks very much
that's Muhammad James June for us and
cave from we're on this we're going to
speak to Muhammad Val in Moscow and
Muhammad has the Kremlin spoken out
about any of these accusations
Tom not today not about these latest
statements from the White House but on
Tuesday the Colombian spokesman Dimitris
beskov he commented on this saying that
we don't have information or specific
confirmation about these so-called
Iranian drones
being purchased by Russia and used in
the front line this should be this
question should be addressed to the
ministry of Defense but he said he knows
that Russia is using its own weapons
with its own Norman clutches on those
weapons by the way these drones uh have
a Russian name on them it's garan which
in Russian language means flower
interestingly also on Thursday the
spokeswoman of the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs Maria zacharova she also
commented on this and she said these
allegations and accusations about these
Iranian drones or alleged Iranian drones
are just conjectures not based on any
facts and she said
that they don't even deserve any
response from Russia she said these are
things that have to do with the problem
between Iran and the West related to the
nuclear fire these are precious these
are just pressures from the West on Iran
to uh to uh get concessions from uh from
Tehran about the nuclear file and they
don't have anything to do with Russia
okay thank you so much there's uh
Muhammad Val in Moscow for us